les soucis judiciaires se poursuivent
pour alexandre benallal ancien chargé de
mission d' emmanuel macron à l'elysée le
juge d'instruction chargé de l'enquêté
sur les violences du 1er mai 2010huit
l'a renvoyé devant le tribunal
correctionnel
et ce pour violences volontaires
immixtions sans titre dans l'exercice
d'une fonction publique port d'armé port
public d'un signe non autorisées sont
renvoyés également devant le tribunal
vincent kraz anciens salariés la
république en marche et deux
représentants des forces de police alors
les soucis d'alexandre benalla avaient
commencé alors qu'une vidéo avait été
publiée on le voyait portant un casque
est frappant un manifestant place de la
contrescarpe eux à paris en marge du
défilé du 1er mai une enquête
préliminaire pour violence volontaire
avait été ouverte
et puis en août 2010 8 une seconde vidéo
avait surgi on y voyait toujours
alexandre bédat la frappant d'autres
manifestants cette fois ci au jardin des
plantes à paris mais toujours le 1er mai
et outre les violences il portait un
brassard de la police nationale elle en
avait bien évidemment pas le droit
alors de tels agissements avaient
déclenché une vive polémique un séisme
politique
et puis il faut ajouter qu alexandre
benalla a déjà été renvoyé en
correctionnelle a cette fois ci pour
l'utilisation frauduleuse de passeports
diplomatiques lors d'un voyage en
afrique et ce alors qu'il avait cessé
toute collaboration avec l'elysée